now antonio brown leaving is just one
part of the humiliation that the
steelers are dealing with because
le'veon bell worked the system to his
advantage and he will be a free agent
because the steelers weren't going to
apply the franchise tag again after bell
sat out all of the 2018 season so
we think he may go to the jets i could
see the raiders get involved here's the
bottom line
what do we think le'veon bell is going
to get per year chris i've got an idea i
want to hear yours though there's a
little price is right here i want to
know what you think bell is going to get
and then i'll tell you what i think he's
going to get okay i think i know what
you say he's going to get i know you're
probably going to say something over 17
million a year something along those
lines i think it's going to be just
north of 15. i think he gets something
like 15 and a half a year something like
that i think he certainly tops todd
gurley as the highest paid running back
in all football but i also think at the
same time teams are going to be able to
point to todd gurley and use that
against le'veon bell and go look look
here's the highest paid guy and here we
were year two of the contract he
couldn't really play to full strength at
the end of the year because of the
running back position i think that'll
get used against him a little bit out of
the fact that he didn't play football
for a year so uh
i'm gonna say he gets somewhere
like four years
north of 60 million with
over 30 million something guaranteed but
an annual average of like 15.5
yeah and here here's the thing every
year we're astounded by the deals that
these guys get because the numbers are
so big
we almost can't comprehend when they go
up and we think when they go up that
it's some obscene jump but the reality
is the salary cap keeps moving north
every year it's 188.2 now it's up
another 10 million it has shot up over
the last five years
and
and and that's why i look at this and i
say you know what 15 million 15 16 was
kind of the number last year that he was
looking for i think 17 is the over under
i think he will do better than 17. now
it may be a five-year deal where there's
a way to massage it and say it's worth
this that or the other i think it's
going to be a short-term deal i think
it's going to be fully guaranteed at
least for the first two years and maybe
half of year three if the jets sign him
that's what they did with with darrell
rivas a few years ago fully guaranteed
the first two and guaranteed a big chunk
of year three maybe all of your three
kirk cousins got all three years fully
guaranteed last year with the vikings
although there's a greater risk of
injury for a running back which could
make the jets or whoever it is more
reluctant to do it but i think it will
be north of 17. we will be we will be
stunned by it but we shouldn't be look
at this chris well
antonio brown getting 30 million
guaranteed from the raiders when he had
zero getting 16.7 million over the next
three years we would have been stunned
by that a week ago knowing that the guy
really had no leverage there was only
one team going after him and he still
got 16.7 and and let me tell you this
le'veon bell is going to want more than
16-7 now that antonio brown's getting
16-7 over the next three years i think
you know even though they were teammates
there's probably a little rivalry
between the two he's going to want to
one-up him and i think he's going to
shoot for 17. he's he already was
shooting for that yeah and i think he's
going to get more than 17. man i i guess
where i just you know that i look at
that a high numb as a high number
because i go okay todd gurley is making
14.3 million per year number two in that
list at running back position is david
johnson at 13 million dollars per year
and then there's a considerable fall off
from that from those two i mean the next
guy in line is devonte freeman at 8.2
million dollars a year so i guess that's
where i go man i just don't envision it
being that big of a jump uh as far as
three million dollars more per year than
the next highest guy at your position if
you're saying over 17 million so we'll
see maybe we um
i don't want to do it i wasn't saying
maybe we do double or nothing on that
stake or why no no no no i don't feel
strongly enough about it you know what
it's probably it's probably smart that
you i i'm i'm always like no one to hold
them know when to fold them no one to
walk away no one to run right i i'm
happy to have one steak dinner but i
think that it would end up being two i'd
feel really bad taking two steak dinners
from you because i think it is going to
be north of 17.
yeah well if you really do then you know
put your money where your mouth is okay
no i'm not that no no no no
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports